The next question was what is the
mechanism of this T-cell exhaustion.
Why are these T-cells not able to kill the
target cells? Why are they not able to do
what the good memory cells do?
So the contrast here was with the highly
functional memory cells with the
dysfunctional cells under chronic infection.
So what we then decided to do
was that we said, "Let us look at the gene
expression profiling of a highly
functional memory cell and compare it to
that of a highly dysfunctional cell."
And the system that we used allowed us to
take T-cells of the same specificity --
and what I mean by that is it's a T-cell
which has a T-cell receptor that sees the
same peptide from the virus that we're
studying, but one was under the
conditions of an acute infection and the
cells are highly functional, another is
under conditions of the chronic
infection where the cells are
dysfunctional.
So we're not comparing apples and
oranges, we'd be comparing different
flavors of the same fruit. And so we
looked at the 20,000 plus genes which
are expressed by these cells, and we
found that there were some striking
differences in the gene expression
profiling of the exhausted cells
compared to the functional cells.
There are many, many differences but what
we were struck with, and that was the
thing that really was the most
differentially expressed between these
two cells, was the expression of inhibitory receptors.
So there are inhibitory receptors
that a cell can
express and these inhibitory receptors
actually inhibit T-cell receptor signaling.
A T-cell receptor is what
recognizes the tumor cell or the
infected cell and its signaling to the
T-cell receptor is needed for the cell to
then kill the target cell. So these are
inhibitory receptors that come up and are
regulating that T-cell receptor.
And the most striking receptor that we
identified in terms of T-cell
exhaustion was a molecule called PD-1.
PD-1 stands for Programmed Cell Death 1.
This was a gene that was cloned by
Tasuku Hanjo in Japan in the early 1990s.
The gene had been around for a long time,
but its function in terms of chronic
infections, its function in terms of
T-cell exhaustion, was not known.
So our studies identified that this
molecule was expressed at very high
levels on these dysfunctional or
exhausted CD8 T-cells. But then what
really clinched the deal here was in a
collaborative study with Gordon Freeman,
who's a scientist at Dana-Farber Cancer
Institute at Harvard Medical School.
Gordon Freeman had antibodies that could
bind the inhibitory receptor. And the way
the inhibitory receptor works is that the
PD-1 will bind to a ligand that's
either on the tumor cell or on the
infected cell. This ligand is known as PD-L1,
L standing for ligand.
It's a molecule that will bind the
inhibitory receptor. So what Gordon had
made was antibodies that would either
bind the inhibitory receptor or the
ligand and prevent the block interaction
between these two. So if you prevent
interaction of the PD-1, which is on
the T-cell, the PD-L1 which is on your
target cell, if that interaction is
blocked, then the inhibition does not happen.
And the results we got were
really quite striking. We showed that if
you take a chronically infected mouse
and you infuse this mouse -- we inject into
these mice antibodies either against the
inhibitory receptor or against the
ligand, disrupting that inhibitory
interaction -- suddenly now you restore
function back in the cells. The cells
begin to expand because they have the
TCR stimulation. They are able to kill
the virally infected cells, secrete
antiviral cytokines, and most importantly,
bring about a reduction of the viral load.
So this was the first demonstration
that this blockade of the PD-1 pathway in vivo
and the condition
of a chronic infection
would restore function back into the
T-cells and result in the control
of the viral infection. So this finding
had a huge impact. This work was done
actually by a graduate student at Emory
University. Dan Barber was the first
author of this paper, and this paper
attracted a lot of attention. This was
published in 2006. Immediately there
was a flurry of papers that came,
and some of those we were involved in
collaborating with our friends,
showing that PD1 also is involved in
inhibiting HIV-specific T-cells.
This was a study we did with Bruce Walker at Harvard.
And then in studies that we did
at Emory with Arash Grakoui, who's a faculty
member at the Emory Vaccine Center,
Arash showed that the same thing happens in HCV-infected people.
People who are chronically infected with Hepatitis C
virus do have CD8 T-cells that recognize
HCV, but they have very
high levels of PD-1
on their cell surface, and that
inhibits the function of those T-cells.
Others showed the same thing with
Hepatitis B and so on. So basically it
very quickly established that T-cell
exhaustion, as I told you, happens in many
chronic infections, but now it is also
shown that a major regulator of the
T-cell exhaustion is this inhibitory
receptor PD-1, and that blockade of this
interaction results in function in
those cells. So think of it as a brake
that's coming on the T-cells, so that the
T-cell receptor... you're pressing
the accelerator because
there's antigen stimulation, but the brake is on,
so basically nothing happens.
And releasing PD-1 is releasing
a brake on the T cells.